the queen is the most powerful piece in  the game Her Majesty has the combined  powers of the rook and the bishop in  this position the Queen on d1 can go all  the way from d1 all the way up the rank  to d8 as well as all the way over to a 1  as well as from d1 to a4 in this  position the Queen can also move like a  bishop to the h5 square and that's a  check to better understand the power of  the Queen let's imagine that white plays  the move between D 1 to D 6 blacks King  has one move in this position and that  would be king f7 if we continue this  line for a few moves we can see that the  White Queen can shadow the black King  and literally place the black King in a  coffin where all those three squares are  controlled by the Queen  additionally the Queen controls the f8  square blacks King is reduced to moving  back and forth between g8 and h8 and  whites King can simply march up the  board to deliver a check